so I'm Lamas I'm from Germany I'm Muslim
and I'm I'm suited up rabbis from
Holland yes and we want to give the
world Muslim Jewish peace message our
heart is united and we think of this
babies in Gaza we hope that they will be
healed and live babies in Israel
together have a future of security and
friendship we hope that our friendship
is just a small stone towards building
that you hope will be all feel
comfortable as a Muslim I want to say to
the Israeli and Jewish people I wish you
peace I wish you security and I wish you
that we could be all together friends in
the future we work on it and I think two
people have to find and then to other
people and more to people and then we
have much of people much of people of
peace and I believe in peace and freedom
and I see that Muslim Jewish are
brothers and sisters I think they can
give together the work much of things we
need to peace for this post and you know
basis and you know we didn't know each
other for you days ago and we are
brothers I will never go to sleep
without thinking of you
and wake up without knowing that you are
there and so to my brothers and sisters
Palestinians in Gaza and everywhere my
dream is that your dream will be
fulfilled
of peace security love compassion and
that the tremendous resources of a new
future that are in you will make the
Middle East not to a place of Tears but
a place of hope for all humankind so I
think my dream is going to be reality
because this is a friendship to you
peace and friendship is not future is
not brief its reality now so listen to
us and try to say thank you very much
thank you